Luke here at the outdo Boys YouTube
channel and it's winter time here at the
abandoned Homestead we've been working
like dogs trying to get ready for winter
we've been getting vehicles unstuck
fixing electrical systems buildings have
been collapsing and hanging out as a
[Music]
family hey come on
in
[Music]
here
I'll go warm up the house you stay in
the warm
car
okay all right and let's get the toilet
seat warmed up
here come
on hey hang up
your well look the family's back at the
cabin you guys excited to be here yeah
yeah this cabin is starting to feel like
a fun place to bring the family and not
just a hot mess but it's late and right
now we're just going to get everybody uh
fed and into
bed I'm sure what
Sal go sit down and have your hot
chocolate we got to dip a peanut butter
cookie in this Jacob do you like the hot
chocolate
yes here guys do you want me to throw up
a sleeping bag there's the Jacob
sleeping bag he Becca before you go to
bed would you like a hot water bottle I
would love a hot water
bottle got a hot water bottle here for
Mama
come on guys get your sleeping bags out
I need get it's
bedtime well guys it's late and the kids
are asleep so I got to put the camera
down I'll see you guys in the
morning you sleep okay babe
yeah oh there cute
D
okay that looks so good momy F mommy do
you like your crepe love
it the toaster was the thing too
many
that's okay so no toaster I was
wondering about that first I fought the
generator get some pants
on let's see we got fig and ginger
Jam why thank
you well today we've got a big project
right now all of our batteries and
electrical equipment is over in that
cabin and that cabin's not heated
Winter's coming and it's going to get
really cold it often gets -40 in the
winter time and if the batteries get too
cold they don't work so we're going to
move all that electrical stuff into this
heated cabin the first thing I need to
do is get all this stuff out of the
way there you
go well how you guys doing good good did
you buy yourself a little track vehicle
yeah I'm a pickup truck guy
now
I don't have a lot of experience with
electrical stuff so I called the guys
from allof grid who installed my system
I'm going to have them go ahead and move
it for me I figure one cabin fire is
enough for a
while wow me hungry for human
flesh
[Music]
you want set off the smoke detector
okay turnning breakers on we
go get somewhere oh that's going to be
so much nicer well now if my leg
electrical system bursts into flames
I'll know about it a lot quicker so 48
the system shuts down 51 is like 20% you
said
51.2 that's that's not too bad huh
that's great that's nice the battery
will work a lot better when it's
warm and so I got the generator now
plugs into the cabin right there and I'm
going to go ahead and move that old
diesel generator and I'll use that
little shed to put my generator and our
solar panels are still here on the back
of the cabin and we got this wire
leading to the main cabin and once the
ground thaws in the springtime I can go
ahead and bury that wire what you
begging you fix in the lock working on
it oh yay yay we'll be able to lock the
door a whole new set of keys to lose
well the next thing I'm working on today
is I'm going to try to clean this whole
mess up looks like the previous owners
were trying to install a bathroom and
they've got kind of half done Plumbing a
composting toilet and they framed out an
area for a shower but we're going to go
ahead and take that all out
here all
righty oh throw it Chuck it throw it I
spilled water
everywhere a whole bunch of water came
out of these pipes you can't have that
in the winter time here in Alaska if any
water collects in your pipes that water
expands when it freezes and it breaks
the pipes and it destroys everything if
there's places where water collects in
your pipes the only way you can
winterize It Is by hooking up an air
compressor and blowing the water out of
the pipes and you'd have to do that
every single time your house gets below
freezing be a massive pain better just
to tear the whole thing
[Music]
out done with all that all right does
does it work do work work yeah
yay
uh yeah
yeah
yeah oh I'll tell you what it feels a
lot roomier in here we're not done yet
but man this is an improvement every
time we pick at this it just gets better
I was thinking about what to do with
this cabin now that I've moved all the
electrical equipment out of it
and I'm thinking I might want a workshop
matter of fact making a blacksmithing
Forge would be really awesome that's
definitely something to
consider go get in the car everyone get
your boots dad I
will all right there we
go we got a lot done today but we'll be
back soon we got a lot more to
do
right
[Music]
in
you
good there we go there's the
light and it's heated and it's heated
well guys welcome welcome to the cabin
well today is Tommy's birthday and it is
a special day and I asked what he wanted
to do and he said go on a trip with Dad
and go hunting and snow Machining so
we're doing just that what do you think
you like it up there it's awesome I bet
it's nice and warm up there oh it's it's
already roasting hot you guys hungry oh
yeah is that
your how much I would get since it's
Tommy's birthday he requested we make
mofu had it was lots of what is that a
okay we're adding
tofu
see it's pretty I'm a dog
dog oh it's so there we go you know if
there's a yeah you like that yeah you
guys like that was it good that
delicious Tommy Are You full Are You
full oh please room you going to make
room for cupcakes yes all right let's do
some
cupcakes hey we're going to make you
we're going to get you a candle you
ready for this
oh I don't light it
yet happy birthday okay you better blow
that
out it's on fire oh that's not good
that's on fire cholate cupcake sure it's
kind of like Li cupcake a yeah that's a
good cupcake well it's late we've got a
lot of fun things to do in the morning
I'm going to put the camera down I'll
see you
then for breakfast we've got scotched
eggs and crumpets you guys down with
that awesome awesome all right let's see
what we got we got ourselves some Scotch
eggs are softboiled eggs covered in a
layer of sausage deep fried in ponco and
they are delicious we're going to try
reheating these in the air fryer here
temp maximum
[Music]
temp
woohoo let's see what we did to our
batteries here oh man that tanked the
voltage on my batteries so using that
air fryer for seven minutes used more
electricity than I've used so far in
this entire trip you see I should have
brought the generator and Ry the
generator while I was using that but you
know we're learning let's see if this
completely blows the circuit or not I'm
a little
nervous
oh it'll be very chilly up there cooking
put a little butter on Ma Amber I took
it yeah then bre D for everyone gets a
whole whole Scotch egg and now Josh have
you ever had a scotch egg before I
haven't okay oh well I'm excited to
document this
moment I mean if you like deep fried
food sausage and eggs you know how can
you not like it Tomy you excited to do
some snow machine yeah yeah little
little
uh all right Tommy should we go take a
look at
this
[Music]
love
it I'm no engineer but it looks like an
ouse in there little
[Music]
dirty you get water in the fuel line it
forms it collects in the fuel filter and
that's where you get your
eyes that wasn't great
I just figured out that I forgot to put
the keys in the ignition for
the with the key
in do you're a mechanical
[Music]
genius that doesn't S sound great it's
going to tear up my
belt but this thing doesn't want to
move this goes to the engine this goes
to the track this wheel refuses to turn
so something's jammed up iced over
rusted up so we're going to hook a tow
strap up to this and see if we can't
break that free and get it to
[Applause]
work
[Music]
hey that that snow machine's like a
ninja it disappears in a puff of
smoke
[Music]
I still can't believe that thing runs I
we should have checked to see if it had
a do not resuscitate order first you
know shall we go double or nothing and
see if we can get the UTV out of here do
it let's give it a
[Applause]
shot today is the day I'm going to get
this broke UTV out of here so I can get
it
fixed there we
go
der go slide out
well we'll see if this Fool's Aaron is
uh going to work or not
here all right that's good shortened up
the tow rope a little bit to help with
getting around turns there are some
questions and
concerns all right here's the first
turn I think have to get a running start
at that hill or you might just have to
do full send just see what
happens so much all
send ah you might still be able to I
think I might be able to do it Fu 1 two
three go job
Bo okay
[Music]
we're going to do a daisy
chain
we did it high five woo yes I'll car the
STP you ready all right all right let's
see if we can keep this from going into
a ravine or smashing into the back of my
truck well we came down the hill and I
underestimated how fast the sled would
go and it caught up and RAM the back of
the truck can I hit the gas to give us
space and then that jerked the toe rope
and severed the toe rope we got some
cracking here we're going to tie a
bowling onto this thing the rabbit comes
out of his hole he runs around the tree
and he goes back down into his hole and
the reason why you use a bowling is cuz
no matter how tight you pull this you
can always untie
it
Tony I think it worked brilliant man I
think it worked that was so
sketchy y this bowling is tight as a
rock the way you get it off you grab the
rabbit's neck you break
it then it just comes right off look at
that some some real successful sketchy
Alaskan crap high five
Tom all right got a tow truck is going
to take this to a repair
guy
oh I can't tell you how glad I am to see
that thing loaded on a truck
finally all right Tom you want to drive
back I do good job Tom you drive like a
champion all right Tom let's get some
lunch going
here ruined his really you know you kind
of well here guys you want some
sandwiches here
let's
grilled cheese sandwiches are hard to
beat
huh well listen guys you want to go uh
see if we can shoot some birds do a
little snow machine
yeah all
righto I'm getting old I fell off my
snow machine a little while ago and hit
my knee really
hard yeah a little Trail here the little
V Trail the V spend the whole winter
under the snow eating vegetation and
they'll Burl out and come along go right
back in there yep there he goes pops
right back in the foxes and the owls can
hear them underneath the snow and we'll
get them through the snow oh yeah those
are bunny prints I think this snow is
only a few days old have rabbit stew for
dinner yeah it's just a really fat
Tweety those are gray jays take care of
that got my Ferrari in its garage here
ooo putting the snow machine away for
the night I got to put heat in all the
fuel when it gets really cold you get
condensation in gas tanks and that forms
water which turns into ice and blocks
your fuel lines and this stuff keeps
that from
happening
but let's see it's I can feel it it's
kind of puffy
rightly got to put my pant leg down I
didn't mean to turn this into a thirst
video you want to watch a movie okay
here Josh it looks like you're going to
have to pick so we got a movie pom Poco
it's a Japanese movie about transmorphic
raccoons that fight urban sprawl uh
we've got Ron nska of the Valley of the
wind the Romantic miniseries north and
south from the BBC see
excellent
[Music]
oh here Tony try this watermelon
flavored licorice watermelon how about
that that's a different texture I love
this the wab be licorice so how these
batteries
[Music]
hold yes um that's
toaster
like a steak
[Music]
right how I how do I do on this it's a
little bit more medium and not quite
medium rare but yeah it'll
work
try there we
go all the meals were Tommy's decision
that's he picked all his favorites oh
that was a good dinner but now now it's
time to do the
dishes in the we had a and
just all right guys it's getting late we
got to get to bed we're going to see you
in the
morning it was 8:30 and nobody's moving
I think we're all pretty
tired
win that first
battle
no mommy did you eat that whole thing
mhm jeez a 10-year-old could have never
done that that is the act of an
11-year-old well that was good but I
think it's time to start cleaning
up time to fire up my massive pickup
truck well it's been fun we got to get
going home but we still got a lot to do
so we're going to be back pretty soon
oh not how about that you guys got
enough room oh this is so much smoother
on the isn't it smoother on the
snow
everybody
out right now I've had him for a
while
okay really hot to I'm I
think there we
go that little 2,000 W generator I had
just didn't have enough oomph to run my
system so we're going to try this 3,000
W
generator
aha got electric
start while I was gone two of my
neighbors helped me get rid of that big
broken diesel generator that was there
so that's where I'm going to put my
generator
now it's charging the system there we go
we've got plenty of juice we can run the
refrigerator if we want to and charge
the batteries at the same time and if I
need to use the toaster and the
microwave the air fryer any of those
things I can turn the charger off and
then I can run those for a few
minutes reup my licorice stash to go
check on the snow machine oh yeah that
is
true what happened oh my goodness look
at this our little garage
collapsed oh my goodness trying to pull
up yeah there's the snow machine
underneath all that I mean I don't know
much about this garage it was up when we
bought the property but I assumed it
would handle the snow because we had a
ton of snow last winter if we're going
to get that out we've got to clear all
this snow and debris off
oh look at that one
[Applause]
[Music]
start oh I got that two-stroke running
smokes like a chimney but it works
back hey Nathan you want to watch a
movie yeah watching Ste boy yeah come
down watch Ste boy with us Bud Tom that
Apple well my brother and nephew are
going to be joining us tonight so I'm
going to go pick him
up just climb up into my big
rig
no I got stuck I can't get the truck up
the
hill and my K truck is not getting up
the hill there's a really icy spot and
the Treads just really aren't gripping
I'm going to go take the Snowman machine
to go get
him what's where's traccoon hey guys you
made it yeah I brought my really crappy
two-stroke snow machine how far isn't it
the truck is really close to getting out
so
see
that wasn't easy but we got it no but
yeah maybe when it freezes up over the
night it'll be a little bit harder and
easier to get
up or maybe it'll be worse I don't know
we'll
see hey guys looking styling now you got
your glasses all right guys you head
Nathan you going you going up there you
see all right guys it's late I'm going
to put up the camera I'll see you in the
morning D I got some bad news though
what I've got weak breakfast that's fine
we we our options are oatmeal or spam
and
toast I like about everything in strain
neck
muscles P so well we got a lot of things
to do today number one we need more
fuel that's empty that's
empty we don't want kids drinking them
no
got some just
[Music]
head we go I had a chance to knock this
little Hill down with the excavator when
I was building the road last summer and
I forgot to do it and I'm going to pay
for it all winter long I just know
it ah
why would I do that let's go get some
gas that was that was a good amount
we're good we're not spilling
gas oh we got a full take of
gas looks like someone had a little
trouble you know you're supposed to
turn we got this we got it over now all
right I hit
it
perfect
[Music]
perfect I'm going to kind of try to
clear out a little Trail here so we have
room to turn the snow machine
around
[Music]
feel
sad There You Go got a nice little snow
machine circuit so the boys can do laps
around the
[Music]
property what to do about
this and this thing is
destroyed my spare tires my motorcycle
some other odds and ends are all buried
underneath this everything that's buried
underne there is at least it's covered
with a tarp so I think I'll just deal
with it in the spring it's a shame I
liked that garage I liked it a lot
I got to sit down I got a problem with
my foot you me and my wife went on a
trip to Hawaii last week and I got a
thorn in my foot and it turned into a
big cyst cut into it with my knife oh my
goodness got this big old Thorn came out
oh feels so much better it's been like
walking on a marble for 3 days still
sore but it's better all righty well I
think I need to do a little Cleanup in
here
has two
machine one of these dead Beetle trees
fell down and we chopped it up we're
going to go haul it over for some
firewood got it we'll get
it good
man
[Music]
that one look a little
big you don't clean things
out much we probably we did what half a
cord yeah maybe something like that
yeah here back come back
so got to shovel the top off that car
we'll get so much snow by the end of the
winter it'll crush the
cab all right okay that's locked all
right we're going to go see if we can
get up that
hill more speed
yeah sometimes it helps to have a little
junk in the trunk
yeah well the sun's about to set and
we're headed home and hopefully you guys
have enjoyed this video I've got a whole
series of videos about fixing up this
abandoned Homestead if you want to see
that check out our abandoned Homestead
video playlist and make sure to click
subscribe I'll see you guys next video
If you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for
watching